あ”ー前髪うぜえ
髪の毛が長いと、目に髪の毛が入って目が充血しちゃうんですよ
こっちの目がもう真っ赤でございます
はじめしゃちょーです！
皆さん私のことをバカにしてませんか？
してるよな...?
かぁーつ！
前髪うぜえ
まああんな動画見てたら皆さんバカだと思いますよ
バカなことしたり、実際に失敗するだろーっていうやつをやって、
実際に失敗したりしているんですけども
動画の内容とか、僕の言動とか動きから見て明らかにバカ要素が大きいと僕は感じたので
今回は僕がですね、まあそれなりに人並みに学力があり、そして教養もあり勉強もできる
頭が良い、天才、秀才、ゴッド！てことを証明したいと思います
僕もですね、それなりに教養ありますよ、もうね、高校の時なんか学年の中で....
過去のことは忘れよう！
過去のことは忘れましょう、今の話です
今回はこちらを準備しました
公立中高一貫校適性検査対策問題集
中高一貫校って何かって言うと...僕もよくわかりません。
あ、ヤベッまたバカとか言われる
わかる！
中高一貫校ってあれでしょ？要するに、高校まで階段式で行ける中学校のことでしょ？
お受験のある中学校のことですね。多分
あーいたわ、俺も小学生の時いた。中高一貫校に行くためにお受験勉強してた女の子がいましたね。
という感じなので、多分この中にはその...小学校、小学校で習う内容のかなり高いレベルが入ってると思われます。
今回は！、私はじめしゃちょーがこの小学校の問題を解きます！
小学校の内容もわからないようじゃ全然男として終わりですわ
今回は私はじめしゃちょーがこの中で適当にパラパラめくった問題をバンッって適当に当ててこの問題を解きます。
5問ぐらいかな5問ぐらい解こうと思います。
やっぱその賢い系男子なんで、確実に全部答えるんですけども、
もしね、もし何かのミスで僕が間違えたとしたら僕は今日...
「前髪を3cm切ります」
さっき見てるようにめっちゃ長いんで前髪を3cmぐらい切りましょう。
え、待って3cmってヤバくない？
3cmってヤバいな...
いいだろう！
いい
今日僕が勉強できるってことを見せたいから！
それぐらいの覚悟を持ってテストに臨もうと思います。
え、まってさとちんさんダウンタウンに出てたの？
ダウンタウン、うそうそうそ...
うそでしょ？
さとちんさんダウンタウンに出てたの？
え？
あー話がずれましたすいません。さとちんさんがダウンタウンに出ててテンションが上ってしまいました。
では連続5問正解目指してやってていこうと思います
ちょっとなんか、中身見せると、ほら、なんか、いろいろね...
ほら...ね...大人の....事情ってやつです！
これ！
来ました来ました国語です！
あんまり見せちゃダメ！国語です
覚えときましょう！
これは余裕でしょ
「飛び跳ねる」へっへっ
「飛び跳ねる」と、あとあれです。
寝て起きた瞬間にすぐ起き上がる「飛び起きる」とかね
ウェーイ
オッケー正解は...
「飛び起きる」、「飛び跳ねる」...
オッケーです正解だと思います！
イェーイ！
簡単だな
これ小学校ですからね、それぐらいは全然出来て当然ぐらいでございます。
これも...ちょっと左寄りでココらへんの...この問題
やべえ...ちょっとまってこれはやばいぞ
ここに、炭酸水、塩酸、食塩水、せｋ..こんなの小学校でやるの？
水酸化ナトリウム水溶液とか小学生わかんないっしょ
炭酸水、塩酸(Cl2)、食塩水(NaCl)、石灰水（Ca(OH)2）、水酸化ナトリウム水溶液(NaOH)の5つがあるんですけれども、
匂いを嗅いだり触ったり舐めたりしてはいけない。
この中で、実験して塩酸(Cl2)と水酸化ナトリウム水溶液がどれかを見分けてほしいという問題でございます。理科ですね。
「顔あるお母さん」だから、赤から青になると、アルカリ性、青から赤になると酸性でございます
炭酸水と塩酸(Cl2)が酸性です。
食塩水(NaCl)は中性で変化がなくて、残りの2つ、石灰水（Ca(OH)2）、水酸化ナトリウム水溶液(NaOH)はアルカリ性。
これでマル2の実験で、塩酸(Cl2)と炭酸水、酸性の方に...マグネシウムリボン(Mg)...確かマグネシウムリボン(Mg)
マグネシウムリボン(Mg)をいれると泡が出てそれが確か水素だった気がします。
HCl(塩化水素)が反応するんだよね...
ちょっと小学校じゃなくなってきたな
こんなのやるって言ったって小学生僕のためでございます。
リトマス紙が青から赤に変わった酸性の方の2つで、
そのどっちかにマグネシウムリボン(Mg)を入れて泡が出たほうが塩酸(Cl2)でございます。
てことはもう片方は炭酸水。これで塩酸(Cl2)はわかります。
マグネシウムリボン....
俺よく覚えてんなこんなの...
というわけでリトマス紙を使ってまず色の違いで分ける、分けた方たちでマグネシウムリボンやらなんかこう金属を入れると、
泡が発生します。それで塩酸(Cl2)と水酸化ナトリウム水溶液(NaOH)が反応するんでその2つが分かる仕組みでございます。
この3Step....正解は....
オッケーオッケークリアです！
マグネシウムリボンって言う言葉自体小学校で使わないな
アルミニウム箔って書いてあったんですけどまあ問題ないでしょう。
一番端は難しそうだな
中間ぐらいにしとこう
ここの！この問題！
来ました。
ちょっとまってこれさ、小学校でこんなのやってんのね
難しいな小学校
さっき見せた図の中の(ア)と(イ)の数を書きなさいと。
(ア)は...100-51=49
34=15
(ア)は15です！
(イ)は超簡単じゃね？
まって...これやばいじゃん
20..48、16。
2000年の冷蔵庫の電気使用量は、同年のエアコン、クーラー...多い。○。
照明器具の...減ってるね、減ってる減ってる。
ウ、1980年の半分以下、ｳﾜｧ半分以下...以下だから含めるから○で
全部○で！
5問問題があったんでけども、15、16、○、○、○でちょっと答え合わせしてみましょう
では答え合わせ行きましょう
15、16...オッケ！
○○○ｱｯ....
ｳｯ...！